[Music]
in repeat offender news submitted by
coffee stains a killer was released from
prison after being deemed too old to be
dangerous but he killed again oh my god
who let him out what country this
country oh my god is he like 95 somebody
got out other than in this country 77 oh
yeah Trump 77 he's running the country
there's a lot of like able-bodied 1773
now that's just heard it's a 97 yeah
yeah Bernie and when McCain ran wasn't
he in his late 80s or something like
yeah he looked well so nine years ago a
judge said that this man named Albert
was too old to be dangerous and that's
he was 77
Oh 77 now also he was in his late 60s
when they said he was too old to be
dangerous oh come on how old was the
judge was he like 20 so that's what this
whole story is like now looking into
like the [ __ ] kind of system do we have
like what the [ __ ] kind of judge is this
it's only fair if you killed the judge
complete even deal this man does only
crimes against women oh don't worry
about him that's pretty cool I'm not one
of his targets that he looks for I love
you oh yeah I feel safe yeah he is very
optimistic okay god I thank God I'm off
the hook yeah so this guy he had served
more than 25 years in prison for his
crimes
so the first occurred 40 years ago back
in 1979 it led Jeffrey Dahmer at least
to [ __ ] home yes is he white
give me Bob oh he's raised [ __ ] yep
oh he looks dead bro I'd let him out to
me like nine years ago he didn't look
like
you should be wearing a robe and sitting
in a very cold place in Game of Thrones
oh no I'm my references are very current
his lawyer looks dead - maybe they did
the [ __ ] what's the tweaking of the
picture please happy Oh No Hey look oh
this guy kills you you couldn't move
faster than two miles an hour no we
killed another old person stand by that
time 77 in this picture you know what
enough I know he looks like he's [ __ ]
105 DNA do we drain the judge again
there's just mold growing like on his
cheek Jones yeah I expect to see a
[ __ ] road crawl up his [ __ ] design
lighting is two men older dude they up
the contrast for sure that's the word I
was [ __ ] was that your honor I'm just
trying to keep my eye inside you can't
even believe he's alive I will look 30
years older than his age let me tell you
the history of his crimes
so back in 1979 his wife 34 year-old
Sandra served him with divorce papers
and asked police to escort him from the
apartment three weeks later she asked
him to come and pick up his stuff then
that's when Sandra's 12 year old
daughter from a previous relationship
was heading in the back bedroom and
through a crack in the door she saw him
bend his mother's arm behind her back
and pushed her into a chair while saying
he he loved her and he didn't want to
hurt her and then after the mom was
screaming the daughter ran downstairs
and asked neighbor to call the cops and
the neighbor passed Albert covered in
blood so he ended up stabbing Sandra 14
times and she lived long enough to tell
the neighbor that her husband did it
Oh and then they police found a
three-and-a-half inch jack knife they
should never have let him out that's
[ __ ] crazy
fourteen times
so there's more than one they keep
letting him out okay so then and when he
was 36 years old that's when he was
sentenced to 30 years in prison
and so I lenient back then yeah what
state is this I mean it's a state that
supports criminals I think so the next
thing was that in 2007 he was arrested
after punching a woman he was dating and
he stabbed her with the fork oh wait
till he got out yeah okay three years
later in 2010 a woman told police that
she and Albert were arguing and that he
put her in a headlock and repeatedly hit
her with the butt of his knife and then
chased her with a screwdriver before she
escaped Oh God and then police found him
trying to hang himself on a fire escape
they stopped them yeah how many other
women did he [ __ ] up that they didn't
report yeah no right he's so predictable
though he always gets the lady in a hole
first before he does something because
the other one was that arm behind the
back and this was a headlock yeah yeah
it's kind of a hack huh yeah so
predictable in 2014 he ran into the
woman that he had assaulted and told her
you'll get yours let me get a full
nelson you don't a full nelson stabbed
her it's a full nelson when you'd like
gonna be like this oh geez just like yes
why I knew it was coming yeah so then um
so he pled guilty to violating his
probation he was sent back to prison
until 2016 and after he was released he
moved to a different city in Maine where
he lived with his nephew and that's
where she met this 48 48 year-old woman
named Kimberly at a library and so
they're saying that Kimberly and her two
boys lived in a shelter and they were
about to move on to their own apartment
he must be charming when Elbert offered
to buy her shoes I was sorry Hurst on
nutritious meals and so then they buy
him nutritious meals they were really
not shoes
I read wrong
okay here's hopeful
okay buy me shoes I was pictured him
being like hey how much for those shoes
there boy like an offering to buy it buy
it
okay so then he was regularly seen with
Kimberly and he was kind of like stalker
Kardashian Kimberly Dobby is her name
yeah so so then he was seen from the bus
stop to the library he would follow her
a lot and then two days before he
decided to kill her he went to Walmart
and bought two pink handled paring
knives and then that's when he trailed
her again on the day of her murder and
hurt like her and her two kids - like
from his Dunkin Donuts - a laundromat
and then they're saying that she had
just put in a load of laundry when she
stepped outside to make a phone call and
she was sitting on the steps tucking her
cell phone while her boys played on the
sidewalk when he went up to her and
stabbed her at least 11 times and so I
guess the whole thing here was like they
stopped counting after 11 if that that's
how they were reported at least 11 and
then so you could have been really
accurate and it's like 22 times but just
each hole was like oh yeah they went
back on the same one but he murdered her
in front of her twin boys oh my god -
witnesses because they mentioned this
other witness who was who had just
happened to be there and she witnessed
it you know why he bought pink candles
because he's like there's no way those
are my knives that's a girl's name
yeah you try to you try to hide yeah
yeah why would my client purchase a pink
knife that's a girl's mouth he's closed
you're right that's not as nice right
despite the fact there's three witnesses
by a jury of your peers yeah so when did
he go Wendy was the judge like you're
too old nine years ago okay so after all
that they're like you know what you're
too old and he killed someone I love it
well maybe he was like I'll prove you
wrong
I'm not
to old what if that spark is yeah he
killed him he's like still got it this
podcast like he got out cuz some podcast
my viral it was like this old guy needs
to be free yeah I guess yeah people are
like how the [ __ ] he did this [ __ ] in
broad daylight like so doesn't give a
[ __ ] the pink knife incident
the most recent one after he got really
oh my they were like he's too old and he
decided to go to Walmart and still kill
with two knives for I don't know it gets
maybe one gets dull and you got to pull
out the other one old and he's like
tired how many times do you go to prison
like three yeah I don't want to call the
Department of Corrections like what did
they fit twice I don't know third one
they were like eTools he is
rehabilitated they rehabilitate [ __ ]
Jesus but not people are like are you
[ __ ] kidding me man like these two
kids lost their mom because you thought
he was too [ __ ] her and then when he
gets released is he gonna ziploc bag
with the two pink ties in it too he does
get his stuff back this is a part of his
things
yeah and why don't we kill people again
in prison I forgot that's one thing I'm
like hey this guy should be on the
electric chair because sometimes I feel
like we should interest they were saying
that the witness that I referred to as
the she was a he Dennis um he ran
outside after hearing can really scream
and then drop kicked him and then held
him to the ground with his foot until it
police if you saw old yeah yeah but that
was just kind of judge was just like man
I know it the sheet says he's only 69
but this dude looks a hundred so like he
can go free he's not gonna hurt anyone
that guy's just like sitting there like
tanning in all of his for like he was
trying to like prisons overflooded and
meme like they can't hold one more guy
who deserves to be there that sounds
like a lifer to me I only have 30 years
of Egan with that's what I'm saying I
hear all the time it's like this guy
murders this person this chick murdered
her husband or whatever and it's like 15
years I'm like wat yeah 15 years it
really smells like [ __ ] and the jail
didn't want
there anymore oh you could have been a
smell thing because he looked he smells
rotten but you hear about that you do
hear about those things cases I've heard
it I don't understand this world
[Music]